there's a lawsuit where people are
claiming olaplex causes breakage hair
loss blisters on the scalp I've also
seen a lot of people saying their hair
is getting worse after olaplex I'm
guessing this is olaplex 3 here are the
ingredients it's basically that Bond
building active with some conditioning
ingredients but if you've ever tried it
you'll know it isn't very conditioning
it makes your hair feel quite rough and
frictiony you need to wash it out and
condition afterwards I've seen people
suggest that too much Bond building
could be making hair brittle but the
ingredient really shouldn't be able to
form more bonds than they were broken to
begin with the formula can keep your
hair wet for longer though and when your
hair is wet it's extra fragile water
swells up hair hair can absorb up to a
third of its own weight in water this
makes the cuticle scale stand up so they
snag and break off more easily if your
hair is wet for too long this swelling
can crack and damage the glue that
sticks your hair together called the CMC
rubbing wet fragile hair coated in a
sticky layer against hair ties and
pillowcases is a recipe for damage
conditioning ingredients can also
irritate your scalp if you're allergic
you can end up with blisters and
bleeding